très bien nous reprenons nous
poursuivons donc les travaux de la
commission d'enquête sur les moyens
mobilisés mobilisables par l'État pour
assurer la prise en compte et le respect
par le groupe Total énergie des
obligations climatiques et des
orientations de la politique étrangère
de la France dans ce cadre nous
entendons aujourd'hui madame Emmanuelle
vargon présidente de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie cette autorité
administrative indépendante est en
charge de la régulation du marché de
l'électricité mais aussi du gaz ce
dernier nous intéressant
particulièrement ici elle dispose
également d'un comité de prospective qui
a publié des rapports sur le biogaz les
biocarburants ou l'électrification
sujets sur lesquels nous reviendrons
avant de vous laisser la parole madame
la ministre pour un propos introductif
d'une quinzaine de minutes il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat la vidéo sera le
cas échéant diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux puis consultaable elle fera
l'objet naturellement d'un compterendu
publié je rappelle formalité obligatoire
en outre qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des peines prévues aux articles 434 13
14 et 15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de 3 à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et de
45000 à 100000 € d'avende je vous invite
madame la Présidente maintenant à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité Rin que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le
jure je le jure merci avant de vous
céder la parole je vous invite à nous
préciser si vous détenez ou avez détenu
des intérêts de toute nature dans le
groupe Total Energie ou dans l'un de ses
concurrents dans le secteur de l'énergie
y compris sous forme de prestation de
conseil ou de participation à des
cénacles financé par les
énergéticiens monsieur le Président
merci je n'ai aucun conflit d'intérêt
avec le secteur de l'énergie et ma
mission même ne serait pas
possible merci votre réponse sera ainsi
mentionnée au compendu madame la
Présidente vous avez la parole pour
votre
introduction merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
vais peut-être commencer mon propos
introductif par présenter brièvement
l'émission de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie pour éclairer
ensuite le rôle que nous pouvons avoir
sur ces différents sujets donc cette
commission comme son nom ne l'indique
pas est une autorité indépendante de
régulation elle a été créée en 2000 elle
dispose de 160 collaborateurs et nous
avons trois grandes mission la première
mission est de réguler les réseaux de
distribution et de transport de gaz et
d'électricité d'enfixer la trajectoire
tarifaire et la bonne utilisation la
deuxième mission est de veiller au bon
fonctionnement des marchés de gros et de
détail d'électricité et de gaz et la
troisième mission qui n'est pas une
mission de régulateur mais qui nous a
été confié par l'État et d'accompagner
le développement des énergies
renouvelables avec un rôle d'expert sur
les arrêtés tarifaires et un rôle
d'instructeur pour tous les appels
d'offres qui appellent au développement
de la production de toutes les énergies
renouvelables électriques et
gazière nous le faisons donc avec les
160 agents que je mentionnais et comme
vous l' Ava dit monsieur le Président
mon prédécesseur a pris l'initiative de
créer un comité
prospective qui a un rôle d'animation de
débat pour éclairer les enjeux et les
prises de décisions publies au sens
large sur des sujets d'enir nous avons
actuellement un groupe de travail
prospective on pourra y revenir si vous
le souhaitez sur la capture du
carbone surtout sur la partie
infrastructure pour voir dans quelle
mesure il faudrait développer une
régulation en la matière la creux est
donc d'une certaine manière à la fois le
gendarme de l'énergie un expert
économique du secteur et l'un des
acteurs de la transition énergétique et
écologique les enjeux des politiques
énergétiques sont en fait à la croisée
de trois grands défis que nous essayons
de prendre en compte dans toutes nos
décisions la protection des
consommateurs la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et la transition
énergétique sans qu'il y ait de
hiérarchisation entre ces trois
objectifs ces trois objectifs ne sont
pas toujours extrêmement faciles à
concilier puisque en période de tension
la sécurité d'approvisionnement et la
souveraineté à court terme va primer sur
les deux autres objectif la protection
du consommateur la compétitivité et les
prix et la transition écologique
puisque'à un moment quand on va chercher
un approvisionnement on va le chercher
un peu dans n'importe quelles condition
ça c'est en période de crise en hors
période de crise la tension est
permanente entre la protection des
consommateurs et la transition
énergétique c'est notre rôle de
contribuer à à résoudre cette tension en
terme de sécurité d'approvisionnement
nous avons été amenés à travailler sur
la régulation du terminal FSRU
d'importation de gaz de Total et je
pense que nous y reviendrons dans
l'audition pour pouvoir vous expliquer
le rôle que nous avons joué sur ce
dossier nous travaillons aussi beaucoup
évidemment sur le développement des
énergies renouvelables nous avons nous
nous situons dans la trajectoire qui a
été fixée par le Parlement et le
gouvernement à savoir une baisse globale
de la consommation d'énergie assez
massive à l'horizon 2050 et à
l'intérieur de cette consommation
d'énergie en baisse une consommation de
plus en plus décarboné donc ça nous
conduit à soutenir les efforts de
sobriété à souvenir les à soutenir
pardon les efforts d'efficacité
énergétique nous avons d'ailleurs rendu
récemment un rapport sur l'efficacité
énergétique dans le bâtiment tertiaire
qui est un des sujets sur lequels on a
des gains potentiels à faire
significatifs et bien sûr sur le
développement de toutes les énergies
décarbonées en particulier les énergies
renouvelables donc je vous le disais en
introduction nous
accompagnons ce développement en étant
instructeur des appels d'offre éolien
terrestre solaire éolien offshore et
biogaz en terme de constat on peut dire
que ce développement a lieu l'année
dernière rapidement sur le solaire si je
reprends les chiffres 3 Gow de solaire
raccordé euh un peu moins rapidement en
éolien 1,1 GW raccordé même si arrive
actuellement en raccordement et en
fonctionnement
les les installations éoliennes des
premiers appels d'offre je pense en
particulier à fécan et à saint-briux
beaucoup d'installations ont été
autorisées et donc nous avons un un
développement potentiel de plusieurs
gigas qui arrivve notamment en éolien
offshore et des projets importants à
venir dans la prochaine PPE
nous travaillons aussi sur les réseaux
je vous le disais les réseaux sont
potentiellement un goulot d'étranglement
si on y fait pas attention en
particulier en électricité la
réindustrialisation avec cet objectif de
décarbonation nécessite beaucoup
d'électricité directement pour les
process de production ou pour produire
de l'hydrogène qui rentrera lui-même
dans des process de production
industrielle je pense à l'acier pour
toute cette électricité on a besoin de
réseau on a la chance d'avoir un bon
maillage de réseau en France néanmoins
les besoins sont importants en
particulier dans les grandes zones
industrielles qui sont les zones dites
de
décarbonation fusse surmer d'unkererque
Le Havre saint-nazer la vallée de la
chimie dans lesqueles des renforcements
des développements de réseaux sont
indispensables réseau électriqu pour
pouvoir répondre aux besoins
d'électrification et décarbonation de
ces zones donc nous y travaillons dans
les trajectoires de développement et de
financement des réseaux ce sera l'enjeu
je du travail sur le Turp qui est le
tarif d'utilisation des réseaux
d'électricité qui démarre maintenant
pour décision fin d'année 2024 et mise
en œuvre sur la période tarifaire
prochaine
2025-2028 enfin nous travaillons sur la
partie développement du biogaz là aussi
avec un accompagnement des appels
d'offres et des tarifs donc il existe
aujourd'hui des tarifs de soutien du
biogaz pour les petites installations un
appel d'offre vient d'être relancé pour
les plus grosses installations et nous
intervenons sur les les schémas
régionaux et sur les les zones de
raccordement la creux a validé 345 zones
de raccordement qui représentent à peu
près 70 % du territoire et qui
accompagne 1200 projets déjà en cours
déjà en production ou à venir pour
environ 25 TW de production de biogaz
par an on en est aujourd'hui à 11 terw
injectés donc on a à peu près 25
terraw poss possible dans les projets
qui arrivent et ceci devra se poursuivre
pour remplacer progressivement le gaz
naturel fossile par du biogaz vous savez
que nos prévisions enfin les prévisions
nationales sont une réduction forte de
l'utilisation du gaz à horizon 2050
selon les trajectoires une réduction
probablement de l'ordre d'un facteur
d'une division par de entre la
consommation de gaz actuel et la
consommation de gaz en 2050 et en 2050
la cible est que le gaz consommer soit
intégralement du biogaz produit
localement à travers des unités de
méthanisation donc nous accompagnons
cette politique de développement du
biogaz peut-être un mot pour finir sur
notre rôle sur les marchés nous sommes
de par la loi le garant du bon
fonctionnement de la concurrence sur les
marchés de l'électricité et du gaz
marché de gros et marché de détail c'est
ce qui nous amène à fixer les tarifs
réglementés de vente de l'électricité et
à jouer ce rôle de surveillance des mar
marché qui s'applique à tous les
fournisseurs d'électricité et de gaz
total faisant partie des fournisseurs
d'électricité et de gaz voilà les
quelques points que je voulais citer en
introduction merci madame la Présidente
avant de laisser le rapporteur puis
naturellement ceux de nos collègues qui
veulent vous interroger madame vous avez
parce que on en est à la 6e ou 7e
audition mais vous avez l'avantage si je
puis me permettre d'avoir été dans
l'exécutif d'avoir donc géré en direct
si je puis dire les problème de la
transition écologique puis les problèmes
du logement mais les problèmes du
logement c'est aussi des problèmes
d'adaptation et puis aujourd'hui vous
êtes à la tête de cette autorité
administrative si je vous
dis depuis le début tout le monde nous
dit réchauffement climatique attention
on va dépasser le degré et demi euh donc
il faut par définition réduire euh
toutes les productions
fossile
euh et en même temps vous êtes chargé si
je puis me permettre de du fait que le
pays ne manque pas
d'énergie ne manque pas de ressources
alors tout à l'heure on nous a dit que
enfin tout à l'heure nous a dit que
l'idéal serait que nous n'importions
plus ni pétrole ni gaz mais comme nous
n'en avons pas jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il faut comment vous feriez
une synthèse de dire qu'est-ce qui est
raisonnable en réalité pour la France
elle n'est pas seule dans le monde euh
nos voisins font-ils autant d'efforts
que nous ou nos
concurrents-ce
que dans la mesure où il n'y a pas
d'autorité internationale parce que la i
c'est des recommandations mais c'est pas
des vraies décisions il y a pas
d'autorité internationale qui dit à tous
les pays du monde nous allons tous cette
année réduire de 5 % demain de 10 % et
cetera comment en vérité on peut avoir
un
parcours de
réduction de la production et de la
consommation en ayant un effet réel sur
le réchauffement climatique parce que
cette évolution serait mondiale est-ce
que nous sommes capables d'imposer aux
autres ce que nous voulons nous vous
imposer à nous parce que moi je suis
très sensible à à cette notion et au
fait que on avance qu'on trouve des
mesur et en même temps je suis tétanisé
par le fait de dire on va imposer à nos
citoyens un certain nombre de mesures
mais si les autres le font pas
euh on va avoir un peu le sentiment
d'être les seuls à avoir des contraintes
comment est-ce que vous imaginez ou vous
pouvez voir quelque chose qui nous
permettrait d'avoir un chemin rationnel
où tout le monde progresse et où les
compes contrainte imposé à nos
concitoyens bah donne des résultats si
je puis dire globaux
et comme vous avez forcément dans le
passé aujourd'hui des liens avec Total
comment vous voyez le comportement ou la
politique suivie depuis quelques années
par Total en la
matière la question générale que que
vous posz monsieur le Président c'est la
grande question qui est extrêmement
difficile à résoudre sur la transition
écologique c'est comment aller à la
bonne vitesse comment y aller tous
ensemble et
comment pousser une transformation en
apportant à la bonne vitesse des
solutions opérationnelles pratiques
simples accessibles à nos concitoyens
c'est pour ça que je vous disais que la
politique énergétique elle est d'une
certaine manière tendue entre trois
objectifs qui sont difficiles la
protection du consommateur c'est-à-dire
une énergie la plus abordable possible
et parfois l'énergie égie fossile est
moins chè que son alternative
renouvelable la transition écologique
énergétique et la sécurité
d'approvisionnement la souveraineté pour
être dans une situation énergétique dans
laquelle on n'est pas dans une
difficulté d'approvisionnement tel que
on arriverait à à du rationnement ou ou
à un manque et c'est autour de ces trois
objectifs qu'on tourne pour essayer de
de trouver l'optimum
donc il y a beaucoup de questions dans
votre question il y a une question sur
la France peut-elle faire ça toute seule
il faut d'abord qu'elle le fasse en
Europe c'est à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne de de cette grande ambition
du Pacte pour le climat et de F 55 ne
serait-ce que parce que il faut il faut
un système de
concurrence équitable entre les
différents pays pour permettre que ceux
qui font des efforts de décarbonation ne
soit pas doublé à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne par des pays qui qui feraient
pas les mêmes efforts le l'Europe la
France c'est 1 % à peu près des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
l'Europe c'est quand même d'tre une
quinzaine de pourcent je suis pas sûr du
chiffre donc plutôt 10 donc plutôt une
dizaine de pour ensuite reste l'effet
d'entraînement possible sur les grands
continents les États-Unis la Chine
l'Asie en général où effectivement il
faut que cet effet d'entraînement se
produise l'effort européen ne suffira
pas tout seul à atteindre les objectifs
climatiques à l'intérieur du pays moi je
crois beaucoup à une transition
progressive dans laquelle on arrive à
proposer des solutions alors je l'ai
j'ai essayé de le faire euh j'allais
dire je l'ai fait mais ce serait un peu
euh un peu trop ambitieux de dire ça je
j'ai contribué à le faire au ministère
du logement en en soutenant très
fortement la politique de rénovation
énergétique du bâtiment avec ma prime
renove pour les particuliers sujet qui
permet d'avancer de faire des gestes de
rénovation et avec le développement de
la rénovation globale il faut
accompagner les Français
au fur et à mesure de cette transition
énergétique dans la capacité de faire
des travaux d'améliorer leur qualité de
vie dans leur logement et de pouvoir
réduire leur facture pour les transports
on a encore beaucoup de questions pour
savoir comment est-ce qu'on peut passer
de la voiture individuelle thermique à
la voiture électrique à d'autres modes
de transport et à un panel de solutions
c'est autour de ce duo solution
accompagnement que qu'on arrivera à
avoir un chemin de de transition
énergétique si je reviens à l'
ça m'amène à un des sujets sur lesquels
on travaille que j'ai pas cité dans mon
introduction qui est d'aider à
positionner la consommation électrique
au moment qui est moins cher donc plus
facile pour le système électrique et
moins coûteux pour les particuliers et
pour les entreprises c'est tout le
travail sur le décalage de la pointe le
soutien aux offres de type herplur
creuse tempo ou toutes les offres autres
offres de marché qui sont du même genre
à chaque fois qu'on a on arrive à
décaler la consommation d'un moment de
pointe à un moment hors pointe on a
besoin de moins de réseau l'électricité
est moins chè et du coup ça réduit
globalement la facture pour tout le
monde ça ça fait partie des des des
solutions très concrètes dans lesquelles
on peut dire on accompagne cette
transition on vous aide à consommer
moins à consommer mieux mais c'est
essentiel pour répondre à votre
question alors moi je n'ai ni dans ces
fonctions ni dans les fonctions
précédentes de visibilité global sur la
stratégie de l'entreprise totale qui
agit en France et à beaucoup d'autres
endroits dans le monde à la creux on on
travaille avec Total comme fournisseur
justement sur cette question
d'accompagnement à une consommation qui
soit une consommation au meilleur moment
on travaille avec total sur la question
de l'approvisionnement on en reparlera
sur le terminal du Havre et total est
l'un des acteurs qui se présentent aux
appels
d'offrees qui sont régi de façon assez
précise par le droit et pour lequel
l'identité de l'entreprise est assez
neutre pour nous nous on regarde les
projets les prix et le reste des cahiers
des charges total on fait partie ils ont
à peu près 5 % des capacités de
production électrique ENR en France et
donc ils
ont régulièrement au guichet d'appel
d'offre comme beaucoup d'autres
entreprises merci monsieur le
rapporteur merci si madame la Présidente
vous avez bien posé les enjeux
souveraineté accès à l'énergie et dans
des conditions abordables surtout pour
celles et ceux qui qui souffrent et puis
évidemment transition
énergétique alors le président a posé
des questions assez fondamentales sur
sur l'articulation de ces enjeux sur la
place de la France dans le
dispositif une des question qui se pose
pour répondre à cette à ce à ce à cette
quadrature du cercle parfois c'est
évidemment
l'exemplarité et le fait d'être pionnier
dans cette transition et d'en faire un
projet de société au sens où on voit
bien que internationalement cette
question de la transition énergétique
est
devenu une guerre économique à bien des
égards sur la question des énergies
renouvelables sur la question de l'accès
aux ressources donc ma question est
finalement est-ce que c'est pas au-delà
de notre responsabilité actuelle sans
parler de la responsabilité historique
notre responsabilité pour un pays comme
la France qui a toujours vocation à
peser sur les affaires du monde est-ce
que c'est pas d'être pionnier y compris
pour en tirer les bénéfices pas
simplement environnementaux mais
industriel
énergétique on a beaucoup délocalisé
dans notre pays si aujourd'hui on recrée
l'industrie c'est bien autour de cette
transition énergétique et puis vous avez
abordé la question évidemment du du euh
du terminal méthanier du Havre euh la
creux a donné un régime d'exception à ce
projet y compris euh dans son
attribution est-ce que vous pouvez
préciser un peu quel était euh au fond
les raisons de ce régime d'exception euh
un premier argument avancé par Total
était la faible rentabilité possible
de ce terminal
métanier on peut toujours s'interroger
sur le fait de faire des exceptions
quand un un groupe annonce près de 20
milliards de bénéfices en quoi au fond
il devrait déroger un régime d'exception
enfin il devrait bénéficier d'un régime
d'exception pour rentabilité moindre
deuxième question c'est qu'au fond quand
on regarde et
là peut-être vous pourrez confirmer ou
affirmer les ports métaniés les
terminaux métaniés français n'ont pas
tourné en 2022
2023 en pleine capacité pourquoi et ben
voilà pourquoi avoir un régime ou un un
terminal méthanier en plus y compris
dans un contexte européen de
construction de multiplication des
terminaux métaniers enfin si vous me
permettez vous avez beaucoup parlé de
GNL ce qui est aujourd'hui la la la
source principale de nos import tion de
de gaz est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
comment vous intégrez le fait qu'une
partie de ce gaz c'est du gaz de schiste
c'est du gaz qui viennent maintenant
d'horizon très différents que
précédemment et en quoi la creux
intervient y compris pour donner
peut-être des recommandations en terme
de souveraineté énergétique
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur pour la première
question je pense que notre intérêt
c'est c'est d'aller aussi vite que
possible dans cette transition et donc
d'accueillir notamment toutes les
solutions technologiques des plus
matures aux plus innovantes donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle on continue à
développer le solaire classique l'éolien
terrestre dont on continue à avoir
besoin l'éolien offshore posé classique
et maintenant nous arrivons au premier
marché sur l'éolien flottant
et pas mal encore de technologies pas
totalement mature sur lesquels il y a
des démonstrateurs en France je pense
aux hydroliennes je pense
potentiellement même à l'énergie
aquatique par osmose la
pyogazéification sur laquelle on
pourrait avancer encore un petit peu
plus vite donc on a besoin de continuer
à accompagner des technologies pilotes
certaines arriveront à maturité ce qui
veut dire possibilité de les
industrialiser à un coût raisonnable
d'autres non mais je pense que c'est
notre rôle dans le le caractère pionnier
de la transition que de pouvoir
accompagner ce genre de projet total
d'ailleurs à l'un des projets pilotes
d'éolien flottant dans en Méditerranée
il y a trois projets pilote dont un qui
est porté par une société qui s'appelle
k dans laquelle le total doit avoir je
crois 20 %. je suis pas tout à fait sûr
du chiffre mais à 20 % de part donc il
faut qu'on continue à accueillir en tant
que pionnier ces technologie c'est aussi
pour ça que c'est très important d'être
dans la dynamique hydrogène avec
l'accueil d'électrolyseur sous réserve
d'avoir suffisamment d'électricité dans
des conditions suffisamment abordables
pour que cet hydrogène puisse rentrer
dans des process de décarbonation
industrielle et permettre d'accueillir
l'industrie de l'industrie actuelle puis
l'industrie de demain mais c'est vrai
aussi pour les usines de batteries donc
je pense que notre rôle en tant que
pionnier il est beaucoup sur le
territoire national d'accueillir toutes
ces technologies après il y a un rôle en
terme de rayonnement international sur
lequel pour le coup la creux n'a aucune
compétence en la matière sur votre
deuxième question sur le terminal
métanier flot temp du
Havre peut-être quelques éléments donc
le premier c'est quand il a été envisagé
un terminal supplémentaire est-ce que
c'était nécessaire est-ce que c'est
toujours nécessaire aujourd'hui on était
en 2022 en pleine crise gazière suite à
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
avec une inversion très très rapide des
flux gaziers traditionnellement le gaz
arrivit par les pipelines de l'Est vers
l'Ouest on a inversé les flux de gaz y
compris en France puisque la grande
connexion que qui existe entre la France
et l'Allemagne qui était
traditionnellement Allemagne vers France
est devenue France vers Allemagne à la
demande de l'Allemagne qui avait
vraiment besoin d'importer du gaz nos
terminaux métaniers tournaient à plein
régime 95 % de fonctionnement et on y a
encore il tourne encore très fortement
80 %
maintenant et la faculté d'avoir un un
outil d'approvisionnement en plus est
apparu comme une assurance
supplémentaire certes beaucoup de term
min métaniier flottant ou pas flottant
se développe ailleurs en Europe mais il
se développe pour les besoins des pays
dans lesquels il se développe et la
France est aussi un pays de transit
justement arrivé par l'Atlantique ou la
Méditerranée jusqu'à l'Europe
continentale donc c'était et c'est
toujours une assurance supplémentaire
c'est un terminal flottant qui a été
autorisé pour 5 ans pas pour une durée
forcément très longue dans une période
dans laquelle on avait énormément
d'incertitude sur les la capacité
d'approvisionnement et de sécurité
d'approvisionnement
donc la creux n'a pas du tout participé
en réalité à la décision d'opportunité
ou à la décision de d'accueil de ce
terminal en revanche la creux a
participé aux décisions du régime
économique applicable à ce terminal en
fait il y a deux régimes possible un
régime régulé et un régime exempté dans
le régime régulé la creux fixe les
tarifs d'utilisation et assure un revenu
garanti à l'opérateur c'est le régime
qui s'applique aux terminaux métaignés
qui sont à fosse et à Saint laser il
existe un autre régime dans lequel c'est
l'opérateur qui prend complètement le
risque et donc ces tarifs ne sont fixés
par personne enfin ils sont fixés par
lui-même et du coup s il a des recettes
enfin si ça tourne il a des recettes si
ça tourne pas il a pas de recette il n'y
a aucune intervention publique ni aucun
financement mutualisé c'est le régime
qui s'applique aujourd'hui au terminal
de derc et c'est le régime qui a été
demandé par total donc nous nous avons
fait l'analyse pour voir s'il était
possible de de de de placer ce terminal
sous ce régime d'exemption donc on av
fait une analyse de marché qui a conduit
à considérer que oui les conditions de
marché permettaiit de créer ce régime
d'exemption dans ce
régime le le le fonctionnement de ce
terminal ne coûte rien aux Français en
gros ni au consommateur ni au
contribuables en revanche pour
accueillir ce terminal il a fallu faire
quelques travaux sur les réseaux de gaz
donc chez GRT gaz pour un montant de 33
millions de d'euros
et total en tant qu'opérateur du
terminal paye une redevance de 8 million
d'euros par an donc 8 million x 5 an ça
fait 40 ce qui veut dire que Total aura
à rembourser un peu plus que la totalité
des travaux nécessaires pour accueillir
ce terminal dans de bonnes condition le
raccorder au réseau de gaz et permettre
la remontée du gaz dans les tuyaux de
GRT gaz donc dans ce régime il n'y a pas
du tout d'argent public mobilisé ni
directement chez le contribuable ni
indirectement chez le cons Atur de gaz
enfin nous avons quand même souhaité
euh valider les règles de
commercialisation donc total à le
bénéfice de 50 % de la capacité pour ses
propres contrats et met aux enchères le
reste les autres 50 % de capacité dans
des conditions sur lesquelles nous avons
délibéré pour nous assurer que cette
mise aux enchères était équitable
transparence et dans des conditions qui
permettent à tous les acteurs de marché
d'y participer donc voilà le cadre dans
lequel c'est s'est posé l'arrivée de ce
FSR et sur votre dernière question
monsieur le rapporteur nous nous n'avons
aucun rôle sur la provenance du gaz nous
avons un rôle de de soutien au
développement du biogaz versus le gaz
fossile sur le gaz fossile lui-même nous
n'avons pas de rôle pour savoir de quel
type de gaz fossile on
parle merci la parole à Monsieur
tisso Merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la Présidente pour votre
présentation fin 2023 la creux a réalisé
un rapport sur le fonctionnement des
marchés du détail français d'électricité
et du gaz naturel entre 2020 et 2022 qui
a montré que la libéralisation du marché
d'énergie avait conduit à la création
d'un oligopole entre EDF ngj et total
Energie la présence du groupe Total
s'explique bien sûr par le rachat Direct
Énergie en 2018 devenu depuis total
énergie électricité et gaz France et
selon la
creux d'après vous comment se comporte
cet acteur sur le marché de l'énergie
en terme de prix de mix énergétique et
d'investissement dans les EnR ça c'est
ma première question et je voudrais
revenir sur une sur ce qu'a dit le
rapporteur sur le terminal métanier au
Havre j'étais déjà parlementaire à
l'époque et on était nombreux à être
étonné de voir apparaître ce sujet dans
un projet de loi gouvernementale et pour
rappel le titre du projet c'était projet
de loi portant mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat à l'été
2022 et moi je me souviens parfaitement
de de ce moment-là et pour rappel cet
article permettait au ministre chargé de
l'environnement le pouvoir de dispenser
d'évaluation environnementale la
construction d'une canalisation de
transport gaz naturel de moins de 3 km
de sur le site portuaire du Havre on
parle bien ici mais vous vous vous
l'avez déjà bien expliqué mais on parle
bien ici d'infrastructure énergétique
privée installé dans une ville quand
même de 165000 habitants quand même et
pour laquelle on décide de se passer
desvaluation environnementale
pouvez-vous nous dire très directement
alors vous nous avez dit que la CRE
avait pas été enfin n'était pas
concernée sur la la régulation mais sur
ce sur ce sujet précisément sur
l'évaluation sur le fait qu'on qu'on
s'exonère de l'évaluation
environnemental pouvez-vous nous dire si
la creux a a été associé à cette
question alors vous étiez pas encore
présidente hein mais mais presque puis
cétait en juillet ou en mai vous étiez
présidente en juillet SIF je sais pas
bien le voilà mais voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire clairement et puis avec
le recul finalement trouvez-vous que
c'est le rôle du gouvernement
d'accompagner de tels projets merci
attendez on va prendre peut-être
monsieur Baros comme ça vous aurez les
les deux interventions une réponse
groupée si je pu dire oui merci monsieur
le Président Madame président alors
c'est vrai que les questions dialogue
les unes avec les autres et vous évquz
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs que la guerre
en Ukraine a attendu le marché
d'approvisionnement français en et
européen en gaz le conflit a mis fin à
des importations par gazoduc en prenance
de Russie en réponse cette situation a
contraint la France à diversifier ses
approvisionnements et en recourant
massivement à l'importation de gaz
naturel liquéfié de façon à répondre à
l'urgence et au besoins des consommateur
et puis aussi de des des états je
reviendrai sur un sur un discours que
vous avez prononcé lors de vos vœux où
vous avez rappeler qu'un même objectif
nous oblige tous à atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 vous avez
ajouté que même dans un contexte de
neutralité carbone où la consommation de
gaz aura fortement diminué les réseaux
gaziers resteront très majoritairement
nécessaires autant pour des raisons
nationales qu'européennes alors dans
cette phrase n'eston pas dans une forme
de contradiction parce que et pour le
coup sachant que Total énergie oriente
sa stratégie de neutralité carbone d'ici
2050 vers une production de GNL total a
ainsi investi dans les réseaux gaziers
dans le gaz de schiste aux États-Unis
Arlington ou au Qatar et ces contction
enfin il a il y a gaz et gaz et on voit
bien que on peut tous souhaiter l'
carbone mais si on est à développer
des des des filières de de GNL sachant
que l'empreinte carbone du GNL est 2,5
fois plus élevée que celle du gaz
acheminé par gazodu on a eu d'ailleurs
la présentation tout à l'heure n'eston
pas face à un moment donné un dilemme et
voilà je voulais vous interroger par
rapport à ce dilemme pas forcément vous
comment vous vous viz personnellement
mais qu'à un moment donné c'est quand
même un phénomène de société et sur
lequel on a intérêt à se pencher
collectivement
merci merci donc sur la première
question je je disais dans mon
introduction total est un fournisseur de
détail d'électricité comme de gaz sur le
marché de
détail le le marché de détail a été
extrêmement bouleversé pendant la crise
puisque les prix ont brutalement monté
des mécanismes de protection ont été mis
en place bouclier et amortisseur et dans
cette période un certain nombre de
clients sont revenus aux offres de
tarifs réglementés en
électricité nous nous n'avons pas de
difficulté particulière avec Total
fournisseur on exerce ce rôle de
surveillance sur tous les fournisseurs
vous avez dit que c'est un oligopole il
reste quand même d'autres fournisseurs
que dfnj est total on a quand même une
dizaine ou une quinzaine de pourcent du
marché qui sont 10 % du marché qui sont
faits par d'autres fournisseurs qui sont
des fournisseurs plus
petits mais en tout cas on n' pas eu de
problème de comportement de Total
vis-à-vis de ces clients ni pendant la
crise ni en dehors de la crise que ce
soit en gaz en électricité en terme de
politique
tarifaire total avait plutôt développé
deux types d'offres à la fois des offres
qui étaient fondées sur les tarifs
réglementés avec une décote en fonction
des moment - 5 % ou - 10 % et des offres
à prix fixes dans la période de crise
aucun fournisseur n'a été capable de
maintenir des offres à prix fixes donc
ces offres ont disparu chez Total comme
chez tous les fournisseurs elles sont en
train de réapparaître aujourd'hui les
offres de Total sont clairement
positionnés par rapport au tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité ou par
rapport au prix de référence du gaz avec
une décotte ou à des prixfixes qui sont
eux-mêmes un peu inférieurs sur la
question du mix énergétique j'en ai dit
un mot total fait partie des entreprises
qui soumissionnent régulièrement avec
des projets éolien terrestr et Solair
total a soumissionné dans un certain
nombre d'appels d'offre éolien offshore
eu et après pour savoir quelle est sa
stratégie pour la suite c'est c'est
vraiment à l'entreprise qu'il faut poser
la question sur le FSRU j'ai pas de
commentaire sur la partie
environnementale d'abord c'est é un
débat entre le gouvernement et le
Parlement donc qui a mené au vote de cet
article dans cette loi nous on n'est pas
du tout compétent pour l'autorisation
environnemental donc j'ai j'ai pas de
commentaire sur ce point-là et et pour
la dernière question sur les réseaux
gaziers B d'abord total n'est pas
opérateur de réseau au sens réseau de
transport ou réseau de distribution en
France c'est grtgas Terga et GrDF qui
sont les grands
opérateurs ce que nous avons mis en
évidence dans un rapport rendu euh au
prier semestre 2023 c'est qu'à partir du
moment où vous faites circuler du gaz
dans les tuyaux même si vous faites
circuler moins de volume de gaz vous
avez en gros besoin d'autant de tuyaux
euh dit de façon un peu plus chiffrée on
considère qu'on est entre 6 et 12 % de
de de canalisation qui pourrait être
fermé quand la consommation de gaz aura
beaucoup baissé à l'horizon 2050 parce
qu'en fait que vous fassiez circuler un
volume important ou plus bas vous avez
toujours besoin du tuyau et si vous avez
toujours besoin du tuyau ce tuyau il
doit être entretenu parce que évidemment
la sûreté la sécurité en
gaz c'est absolument indispensable donc
le niveau d'exigence est le même que le
volume soit 100 ou que le volume soit 50
par ailleurs avec les terminaux métagés
actuels même sans le FSRU on est
redevenu un pays de transit mais c'est
aussi vrai du transit du gaz qui arrive
par le les Pline en Espagne et qui peut
maintenant traverser la France jusqu'à
sortir vers l'Europe du Nord donc on
reste un pays de transit et donc c'est
la consommation française mais c'est
c'est aussi à la consommation à
l'échelle européenne qui va dimensionner
les tuyaux donc notre enjeu est
d'arriver à trouver comment financer le
maintien d'un entretien d'un d'un parc
de d'un réseau de transport et de
distribution alors même que la
consommation baisse et que la cible pour
arriver à la neutralité c'est bien
d'avoir en 2050 une consommation qui ne
soit plus que du biogaz enfin du gaz non
fossile donc une consommation à peu près
réduite de moitié par rapport à
aujourd'hui du coup enfin total est pas
directement impliqué dans cette équation
là à part en tant que fournisseur de gaz
fossile mais enfin la creux fait ses
meilleurs efforts pour accompagner cette
montée progressive du biogaz cette
diminution progressive du gaz fossile on
a d'ailleurs eu un débat avec GrDF sur
le tarif de distribution dans lequel on
considère que il y avait peut-être un
peu trop de volonté de communication de
GrDF sur la promotion du gaz alors même
que on sait que le gaz est une énergie
qui doit réduire progressivement et être
totalement transformé en biogaz donc
voilà c'est sujets sur lesquels on
travaille au
quotidien s'il y a un autre intervenant
par les deux non pas de regret allez-y
oui juste madame les ministre une petite
question un peu politique j'en conviens
sur l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité 9,8 % sur les tarifs en
heure pleine et heure creuse 86 sur les
tarifs de de base donc je voulais savoir
si vous pouvez n donner votre sentiment
dans un moment où on a plutôt intérêt à
encourager les les Français à
privilégier l'électricité dans leur
consommation merci monsieur le sénateur
que cette augmentation elle se décompose
en deux morceaux le prix de
l'électricité elle-même et ce prix de
l'électricité s'est maintenant stabilisé
donc la part approvisionnement des
tarifs réglementés de de vente de
l'électricité est stable entre le
dernier calcul que nous nous avons fait
pour le 1er février dernier et le niveau
qui était dans le Bouclier de la période
précédente l'augmentation est d à
l'augmentation progressive des taxes qui
reviennent progressivement à leur niveau
d'avant bouclier elles ne sont pas
encore revenues à leur niveau d'avant-
bouclier parce qu'elles sont encore
inférieur au niveau avant bouclier le
bouclier en fait il était en deux
parties une baisse exceptionnelle des
taxes et une subvention exceptionnelle
la subvention exceptionnelle a disparu
le le prix de de l'électricité elle-même
maintenant est plutôt orienté à la
baisse les taxes reviennent
progressivement en fonction d'une
décision qui est une décision du
gouvernement et qui a été ouverte dont
la possibilité a été ouverte dans la
dernière loi de financeces reviennent
progressivement à leur niveau intérieur
donc c'est comme ça que s'explique cette
augmentation du prix de
l'électricité madame la Présidente en
fait au travers de la question de notre
collègue euh moi j'aurais tenté de dire
mais c'est pas une question et vous
n'êtes pas en tant que présidente de la
creux responsable mais on veut tous la
transition écologique mais au point de
départ enfin en tout cas pour s'y mettre
ça coûte et comme ça coûte et que on a
un peu plus de 3000 milliards de dettes
c'est sûr qu'on a un peu l'impression
que d'un côté on fait des efforts mais
que de l'autre côté par exemple sur
l'électricité bah l'état voudrait bien
récupérer ses taxes quoi c'estàdire
que comme vous le disiez c'est si je
peux me permettre le vrai élément c'est
il faut trouver le chemin raisonnable
pour à la fois avoir à peu près à peu
près un équilibre financier de
l'État une situation correcte pour les
ménages et les entreprises et quand même
progresser bah c'est sûr que c'est plus
facile quand on a ni
dette ni déficit mais on va faire avec
merci infiniment madame la Présidente si
vous me permettez monsieur le
Président dans la poursuite de ça la
question évidemment qui supporte les
augmentations
à la fois si on avait pas de problème de
dette et si on avait pas de pauvre ça
serait plus facile on a des pauvres et
donc toute la question de la
tarification c'est évidemment de sa
dimension sociale mais si vous me
permettez une dernière question pour
revenir sur un de vos
propos sur le fait que au fond la creux
n'a n'a rien à dire ou n'a pas le champ
de compétence sur l'approvisionnement en
gaz c'est quand même un terrible trou
noir dans l'équation que vous devez
résoudre vous devez résoudre une
équation en terme de prix en terme de
garantie d'approvisionnement et au fond
de ne pas vous intéresser à la
provenance du
gaz parce que faire du GNL plutôt
que du gaz venant par gazoduc ça change
fondamentalement notre relation au
contrat aux conditions du marché
international de la même façon ne pas
s'intéresser si c'est du gaz de chiste
tout du gaz conventionnel pose quand
même encore une fois un problème de dans
votre équation
non alors nous nous ne sommes pas en
charge des autorisations
environnementales et de cette partie-là
de la politique
public ce qu'on regarde plutôt c'est la
sécurité d'approvisionnement au sens des
contrats et donc ce qu'on ce que nous
souhaitons et ce pour le quoi nous
souhaitons pouvoir avoir une action
c'est de vérifier que les fournisseurs
sur le marché de gros et derrière sur le
marché de
détail ont une sécurité
d'approvisionnement à travers des
contrats long terme qui protège les
consommateurs qui sont eux-mêmes liés
aux fournisseurs par des contrats donc
c'est c'est l'un des sujets que nous
avons proposé au gouvernement dans
l'avant projet de loi souveraineté
énergétique de renforcer les obligations
prudentielles des fournisseurs pour dire
un fournisseur qui s'engage à vous faire
un contrat pour 1 an pour 2 ans ou pour
3 ans il faut qu'il soit couvert pour la
la même durée donc il faut qu'il ait
lui-même limité son risque pour éviter
d'avoir des fournisseurs qui vous font
des des contrats intéressant mais qui en
fait ne sont ne seront pas capables
d'honorer parce que eux-mêmes n'ont pas
couvert leur approvisionnement nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est plutôt la
maturité de l'approvisionnement donc le
type de contrat long terme et d'ailleurs
dans une ancienne disposition entre
l'État et ngj sur les le contrat de
service public avait l'idée que NJ
devait assurer une couverture à long
terme de ses obligations dans le système
des tarifs RG monter en revanche pour
l'instant on n' pas de compétenence et
du coup voilà on ne regarde pas le le le
type de de gaz est-ce que c'est du gaz
par gazoduc est-ce que c'est du gaz qui
arrive en GNL mais vous pouvez avoir des
contrats de long terme en GNL donc on n
pas forcément gazoduc contrat de long
terme GNL approvisionnement de court
terme donc c'est c'est cette équation là
nous on la regarde par la sécurité du
consommateur plutôt sur la partie
économique donc sur les prix
merci madame la Présidente merci d'être
venue pour cette audition et je rappelle
à tous nos collègu que la prochaine
audition est lundi après-midi merci à
vous madame la
Présidente